ok erst dachte ich das ist total
bescheuert dann dachte ich was für ein
drama und dann stellte sich heraus das
ist alles total interessant ist und
jetzt gibt es ein video dazu sagen wir
an mit dieser schlagzeile von merkel bis
kim kardashian welche promis haben die
vertrauenswürdigsten gesichter und zwar
nicht anhand von umfragen sondern laut
eines computer algorithmus zur haute kim
kardashian hat mit einem score von 92
prozent das vertrauenswürdigste gesicht
das haben ein britisches boulevardblatt
dasteht öfter mal und sind drin vor
allem was sind diese 92 prozent
überhaupt und was sind 100 prozent aber
die wissenschaftler de zitiert werden
die haben tatsächlich ganz frisch eine
studie veröffentlicht die sich
tatsächlich um einen maschinen learning
vertrauenswürdigkeit o meter dreht und
jungen über das ein drama in meiner
science mit twitter babbel nachdem der
chefwissenschaftler dieser studie die
ergebnisse in einem twitter feld
vorstellte gab es so viele negative
reaktionen dass er seinen
twitter-account zwischenzeitlich
gelöscht hatte was genau an dieser
studie so problematisch war und was
unser gesicht über unsere
vertrauenswürdigkeit verrät das klären
wir jetzt holt euch im tee macht es euch
gemütlich wir steigen durch schauen wir
doch mal etwas genauer auf dieses
silence twitter drama womit hatten so
viele leute ein problem ja ja viele
waffen den wissenschaftlern vor mit
ihrem algorithmus chronologie zu
betreiben und kein seriöser
wissenschaftler möchte sich renault logi
vorwerfen lassen oh nein
was ist phänologie das ist fridolin
springen wir mal kurz der geschichte zu
den anfängen der moderne neurologie
während heute klar ist dass das gehirn
der ort unseres bewusstseins unserer
fähigkeiten und eigenschaften ist hatte
man im 18 jahrhundert nur eine sehr vage
vorstellung davon man hat zum beispiel
beobachtet dass bestimmte verletzungen
am hinterkopf dazu führen können dass
die menschen erblinden obwohl die augen
an sich noch völlig in ordnung waren und
solche dinge ließen die ärzte damals
vermuten dass das gehirn eben ort von
sinnen und persönlichkeit ist
und dass bestimmte hirnregionen für
bestimmte funktionen zuständig sind der
arzt franz joseph gall befasste sich
besonders intensiv kontakt geil stammt
aus der nähe von pforzheim genau wie
unser neues mitglied jens kahl ordnete
verschiedenen hirnregionen verschiedene
persönlichkeitseigenschaften zu von mut
bis zu farben sind solche darstellungen
habt ihr vielleicht schon mal gesehen
und das ist sehr spannend denn damals
gab es ja noch gar keine modernen
methoden wie mrt oder ct scans und
gehirne zu untersuchen wie hat gall also
diese verschiedenen regionen ermittelt
mit einer methode die heute auch noch
sehr häufig verwendet wird nämlich
sachen einfach ausdenken können das war
jetzt ein bisschen fies fall übertrieben
aber er hätte es sich genauso gut
einfach ausdenken können und zwar gaal
kam auf seine theorie in dem er die
schädel formen ganz vieler verschiedener
menschen untersuchte um diese dann mit
deren persönlichkeitseigenschaften zu
verbinden zum beispiel war davon
überzeugt dass witzigeren menschen
stärker ausgeprägtere stirn höcker haben
als weniger witzige menschen denn seine
theorie war dass die hirnregionen die
für witz zuständig ist hier vorliegt die
dann bei witzigen menschen stärker
ausgeprägt ist und damit auch deren
schädel mehr nach außen gestülpt ist
ich habe er wenig wird übrigens diese
idee die persönlichkeit eines menschen
anhand der kopf oder gesichtsform
ablesen zu wollen ist nicht neu die gab
es auch schon lange vor egal bekannt als
physiognomik aber durch geil hatten
physiognomik fans dann plötzlich die
möglichkeit ihre idee eine vermeintlich
wissenschaftliche basis zu geben denn
geil soll wie verrückt daten gesammelt
haben er sammelte menschliche und
tierische schädel wüsten von berühmten
oder berüchtigten persönlichkeiten last
tausende von biografien untersuchte
unzählige totenmasken und so weiter und
so fort
bei allem eifer war seine methode nicht
sehr wissenschaftlich denn wenn man will
findet man leicht zusammenhänge wo
eigentlich gar keine sind diese zwei
leute waren gemein zu mir und sie haben
beide schmale gesichter das kann kein
zufall sein
hat man diese verbindung erst mal im
kopf greift der konfirmation bayers wenn
ich davon überzeugt bin dass menschen
mit schmalem gesicht gemein sind dann
fällt mir diese verbindung im alltag
viel eher auf und wenn ich mal jemanden
treffe deren schmalz gesichert aber doch
nicht gemeint ist dann denken dass
entweder nicht auf oder ich tu's als
zufall ab oder ich rede mir dann ein
sonett war die jetzt auch wieder nichts
und doch lebt egal letztendlich einen
grundstein für die moderne neurologie
denn er hatte grundsätzlich recht dass
verschiedene eigenschaften in bestimmten
hirnregionen verortet sind mit modernen
labormethoden kann man das heute
bestätigen
zum beispiel liegt das wichtigste
zentrum der sprach produktion im
sogenannten prog areal auf der linken
seite des frontallappens wird diese
hirnregion beschädigt zum beispiel
schlaganfall kann man nicht mehr
sprechen aber kann sprache meistens
trotzdem noch verstehen allerdings
erfüllt ein hirnareale oft viele
funktionen gleichzeitig ja mit dollars
zum beispiel unter anderem zuständig für
emotionales lernen und gedächtnis
verarbeitung von belohnung und strafe
und passend zum thema die einschätzung
ob für ein gesicht vertrauenswürdig
finden außerdem beruhen viele
eigenschaften auf dem zusammenspiel
mehrerer hirnregionen und während gall
dem kunstsinn eine bestimmte hirnregion
zuschrieb wissen wir heute dass beim
kreativen arbeiten mehrere netzwerke
verschiedener hirnregionen aktiv sind
und wenn man nach unterschieden zwischen
künstlern nicht künstlern schaut dann
findet man diese unterschiede vor allem
in den verbindungen zwischen den
regionen in diesen netzwerken
franz-josef gaals idee von schubladen
hirn war also viel zu einfach gedacht
aber vor allem ist diese ganze
vorstellung persönlichkeitseigenschaften
von der schädelform ablesen zu wollen
nachweislicher murks es kommt zwar vor
dass das volumen bestimmter hirnregionen
tatsächlich in verbindung steht mit
stärker ausgeprägten eigenschaften zum
beispiel findet man bei londoner taxi
fahrern die einen riesigen stadtplan im
kopf haben einen größeren hinteren
hippocampus als blond oder busfahrern
die nur ihre guten kennen müssen nur
ohne einen kernspintomographen kann man
das nicht sehen also
er sei dem mann schneidet die schädel
von taxifahrern und busfahren auf und
vermisst ihr gehirn will damit sagen ihr
werdet nicht von außen an der
schädelform ein taxifahrer erkennen und
was dort zu bestehen in dieser studie
wurde explizit analysiert gibt es einen
zusammenhang zwischen bestimmten schädel
höckern und bestimmten eigenschaften wie
sie von gall und co postuliert wurden
also sind sie jetzt menschen mit
ausgeprägteren musik höckern wo auch
immer die dann liegen auch tatsächlich
öfter berufsmusiker usw
die daten tausender matthies wurden dazu
ausgewertet doch es waren keine
derartige zusammenhänge zu sehen war es
nicht verwunderlich ist denn das zweite
ergebnis dieser studie war es gibt
praktisch keinen zusammenhang zwischen
gehirn form und schädel vor diese ganze
schädel lehre die franz joseph gall eben
fredo logi nannte ist ganz klar eine
pseudowissenschaft und eine ziemlich
gefährliche noch dazu fangen wir mal mit
etwas für sich harmlosen an
im 19 jahrhundert wurde phänologie
angewendet um anhand der kopfform treue
von untreuen ehemännern zu unterscheiden
was aus heutiger sicht vielleicht auch
amüsant scheint aber trilogie wurde in
der geschichte leider auch immer wieder
benutzt um diskriminierung und
menschenverachtung wissenschaftlich zu
rechtfertigen indem man anders
aussehenden menschen schlechte
charaktereigenschaften zuschrieb wie zum
beispiel schwarzen während die sklaverei
in den usa oder juden im
nationalsozialismus dann wollte zum
beispiel faulheit dummheit oder
boshaftigkeit an der kopf oder
gesichtsform ab
der italienische arzt im
kriminologischer renault so bezog sich
auf die phänologie um vermeintlich
geborenen verbrecher ihre kriminelle
veranlagung im gesicht abzulesen
diese veu kriminologische idee wurde
natürlich auch vor den nazis
aufgegriffen um ihre eigenen verbrechen
zu rechtfertigen vertrauenswürdigkeit am
gesicht ablesen zu wollen ist also
insgesamt eine ziemlich blöde und genau
deswegen haben die autoren dieser studie
so starken gegenwind erhalten wobei ist
das denn wirklich das was sie gemacht
haben wir es diese studie man genauer
die technik um die sich der
vertrauenswürdigkeit tomate dreht ist
ein maschinen learning algorithmus wie
funktioniert das sagen wir ich
programmiere ein algorithmus
der fotos von roberts ski hamstern und
phasen unterscheiden kann beides sind
nagetiere beide können zumal
lieblingstieren aber rogowski hamster
sind zum beispiel die kleiner was auf
fotos schwierig zu erkenntnis aber sie
sind auch viel runder wären zwei phasen
denn sie pfeifen sogar kurzfristig einen
hals bekommen bei machine learning
füttere ich jetzt der algorithmus mit
datensätzen in denen er nach bestimmten
mustern sucht also der algorithmus kann
lernen das charakteristisch für borowski
ist das eine runde form hat und so
weiter
und nachdem er dann trainiert ist kann
ich ihm dann ein unbekanntes foto von
einem roboter in zwei phasen geben und
das kann er dann erkennen allerdings
kann dabei auch einiges schieflaufen
forscher der uni tübingen haben zum
beispiel einen fisch erkennungs
algorithmus analysiert und dabei
festgestellt dass der algorithmus die
fischart schleier anerkennt das sind
menschliche finger weil die schleier ein
beliebter sport fisch ist und dass
deswegen frischem fisch einfach sehr
viele fotos gibt wohl von anglern so
gehalten wird so dass das das
charakteristische merkmal wurde kurz
gesagt machine learning kann gut
funktionieren kann aber auch in die hose
gehen damit zurück zur studie was war
jetzt das prinzip hinter diesem
vertrauenswürdigkeit meter die forscher
haben sich künstlich hergestellte bilder
von gesichtern die mal in einer anderen
studie von verschiedenen leuten in ihrer
vertrauenswürdigkeit bewertet wurde
diese bilder zusammen mit ihren
bewegungen wurden dann eine maschinen
learning algorithmus gefüttert und der
sollte dann auch eben bestimmte muster
erkennen zb das lächeln oder große augen
als besonders vertrauenswürdig bewertet
werden und der trainierte algorithmus
soll dann anschließend erkennen bei
irgendeinem unbekannten gesicht wie
vertrauenswürdig dieses gesicht von den
teilnehmern bewertet werden würde das
wendeten die forscher nun an und zwar
auf gemalte historische porträts von
1500 bis heute über die der algorithmus
im voraus sagte wie vertrauenswürdig die
jeweils bewertet werden würden und dabei
kam heraus je neuer die porträts desto
höher die empfundene
vertrauenswürdigkeit algorithmus ok aber
was war jetzt daran so problematisch
das jetzt renault logi genau genommen
nicht denn der algorithmus misst ja gar
nicht wie vertrauenswürdig leute sind
sondern nur wie vertrauenswürdig sie
wirken und das ist ein wichtiger
unterschied
trotzdem ist diese studie problematisch
und zwar aus drei gründen erstens
statistisch signifikant aber unbedeutend
die frage ist wie gut ist dieser
algorithmus eigentlich also wie gut ist
er darin die bewertung von gesichtern
korrekt voraus zu sagen
seine voraussage kraft war statistisch
signifikant
das klingt immer so überzeugend aber
statistisch signifikant heißt in der
stochastik erstmal nur dass dieses
ergebnis höchstwahrscheinlich nicht
zufällig war und dass das im
zweifelsfall gar nicht viel bedeuten
muss seht ihr selbst hier im diese daten
wolke zu finden muss man ins upland also
den anhang des papers schauen und das
wundert mich nicht denn das ist leider
diese geil also nur um sich das mal
klarzumachen gesichter die jetzt zum
beispiel von den leuten mit null also
als neutral bewertet wurden erhielten
vom algorithmus eine komplette range von
-2 bis +2 aber gehen wir meinetwegen mal
davon aus dass sich dieser algorithmus
noch verbessern könnte
selbst dann bleibt eine fragwürdige
interpretation wieso haben die forscher
diesen algorithmus überhaupt
programmiert was war die motivation
hinter dieser forschung verkauft wird
das ganze so wir können natürlich nicht
in der zeit zurückreisen und die
menschen von damals befragen aber
stattdessen können wir unseren
algorithmus befragen das klingt ja ganz
cool aber der algorithmus gibt uns denn
überhaupt keinen einblick in die
wahrnehmung von damals denn gefüttert
ist er mit daten von heute keine ahnung
und menschen im sechzehnten jahrhundert
gesichter genauso bewertet hätten
letztendlich hätte man bei dieser studie
genausogut menschen heute befragen
können der vorteil von der algorithmus
ist nicht irgendwie quasi zeitreisen
sondern nur dass man größere datenmengen
schneller auswerten kann
vorausgesetzt natürlich es funktioniert
außerdem liehen sich die forscher
ziemlich weit aus dem fenster mit ihrer
historischen interpretation sie meinen
nämlich das porträt zimmer
vertrauenswürdiger scheinen spiegele das
wachsende vertrauen in der gesellschaft
die demokratisierung und den wachsende
lebensstandard wieder ja das müssen wir
mal von einem kunsthistoriker checken
lassen aber ich hätte da noch andere
plausible interpretationsmöglichkeit zum
beispiel ist bekannt die attraktiver wir
jemanden finden desto mehr vertrauen wir
diese person auch und diese korrelation
ist sehr stark so viel zu kim
kardashians hohen score und da sich
schönheitsideale im laufe der zeit
ändern kann es sein dass porträts umso
mehr unserem heutigen schönheitsideal
entsprechen je neuer sie sind und
deswegen auch zunehmend
vertrauenswürdiger wirken also ich weiss
ich mir scheint es als wollten die
autoren dieser studie eine große story
herbeischreiben wo eigentlich gar keine
ist und das passt leider auch zum
dritten punkt unsaubere kommunikation
noch mal diese studie betreibt keine
chronologie oder physiognomik der
algorithmus bewertet nicht anhand von
gesichtern wie vertrauenswürdig menschen
tatsächlich sind sondern nur wie sie
wirken aber eben dieser wichtige
unterschied wird im titel und im
abstract also in der zusammenfassung
nicht deutlich nur wenn man sich die
methoden genau durchliest schenkt man
dass es sich hier um empfundene
vertrauenswürdigkeit handelt wenn man
aber nur titel und abstract liest was
die meisten machen klingt es so als
hätte man hier ein algorithmus
programmiert der tatsächlich
vertrauenswürdigkeit am gesicht erkennt
es klingt natürlich auch wie aufregender
und kein wunder dass zeitungen vita sun
begeistert darauf aufspringen und dieses
missverständnis dann auch noch einen
breiten publikum vermitteln und so wie
ich den artikel hier verstehe haben die
autoren der studie tatsächlich mit das
land zusammen gearbeitet um die
celebrity gesichter auszuwerten solange
man nur das macht ist ja alles noch
irgendwie spaßig aber wenn man auf dem
schirm hat sie oft und vor allem die
böse phänologie und physik nur mit im
laufe der geschichte benutzt wurden um
wissenschaftlich diskriminierung zu
rechtfertigen können solche späße
natürlich gefährlich werden wenn dieses
wissen an die falschen leute ich denke
nicht dass die wissenschaftler dieser
studie das irgendwie böse meinten ich
glaube die wollen ihre arbeit einfach zu
gut und aufregend wie möglich verkaufen
und sind dabei leider so ein bisschen
übers ziel hinausgeschossen und wir
können wir mal ob da vielleicht sogar
ein bisschen mitfühlen
weil wir wissen wie wichtig und
schwierig es ist wissenschaftlich war
kraft zu verpacken damit die leute einem
zuhören aber natürlich darf das nicht
auf kosten der korrektheit gehen und
dann muss man auch als wissenschaftler
verantwortung dafür übernehmen dass die
arbeit nicht missverstanden wird aber
das wichtigste bei wissenschaft es
ohnehin das sachliche kritik auch
wirklich ernst genommen wird und so hat
die redaktion des journals in dem diese
studie veröffentlicht wurde inzwischen
eine notiz hinzugefügt dass sie noch
eine auseinandersetzung mit der kritik
veröffentlicht werden also es bleibt
spannend
unsere keks empfehlungen gehen heute
raus an die ohnehin keks würdigen
kollegen von simplicissimus die haben
ein sehr gutes video gemacht indem sie
die korona berichterstattung der bild
analysieren und für alle die sich mehr
für maschinen learning und künstliche
intelligenz interessieren haben wir hier
noch ein video über brain machine
interfaces für euch wir sehen uns in
zwei wochen und bis dahin bleibt sicher